y sin viajar a favor 61 en contra 60
determinó que el proyecto de ley de
presupuesto para 2021 ha sido aprobado
agua hay un presupuesto para el estado
de israel
[Aplausos]
un triunfo para el gobierno de coalición
de naftalí bennett el parlamento israelí
aprobó su primer presupuesto en más de
tres años anticipándose a la fecha
límite del 14 de noviembre para evitar
un nuevo colapso en el gobierno y
elecciones anticipadas
después de años de caos hemos formado un
gobierno controlamos la variante delta y
ahora gracias a dios' aprobamos un
presupuesto para israel la coalición
gobernante de benet tiene un margen muy
estrecho de 61 escaños entre los 120
miembros del parlamento la alianza está
conformada por ocho partidos dispares
desde ultras nacionalistas hasta
islamistas unidos principalmente por su
oposición al ex primer ministro benjamin
netanyahu el presupuesto de 194 mil
millones de dólares incluye casi 10 mil
millones de dólares en fondos durante
los próximos cinco años para mejorar las
condiciones de la minoría árabe de
israel incluida la lucha contra el
crimen en vecindarios árabes una de las
condiciones exigidas por el partido rap
de mansur abbas para su apoyo además el
ministro de finanzas dijo que la
coalición está unida en otros tres temas
como la necesidad de estabilidad
política la reducción del costo de vida
y la lucha contra los atascos de tráfico
el siguiente paso es aprobar el
presupuesto del próximo año para ello el
parlamento tiene un respiro ya que debe
aprobarse para finales de marzo de 2022